au sommaire le sentier de la source
manouille à salazie la curiosité de la
semaine la maison folio à hell-bourg
direction le fond du cirque de salazie
après avoir atteint hell-bourg continuer
en direction d' il est avide hot à cette
intersection la source manou y est
indiqué sur votre gauche vous pourrez
vous garer au départ du sentier pour
cette randonnée de 6 km en aller retour
prévoir de quoi vous protéger du soleil
et de la pluie des vivres et une réserve
d'eau
la source ou les sources manouille ont
été découvertes par hasard en 1916 par
un jeune de salazie qui leur a laissé
son nom
ce sont des sources chaudes ferrugineuse
situé dans la ravine dans laquelle la
rivière du mât prend naissance pour les
rejoindre
la randonnée en aller retour depuis il
est avide ott est la solution la plus
facile
une première montée est assez raide de
300 mètres permettent une bonne mise en
jambe
un sentier régulièrement traversé par de
petits cours d'eau dans une ambiance
agréable
l'ensoleillement important de ce versant
exposées au nord a toutefois favoriser
le développement de nombreuses espèces
exotiques joli à regarder mais
envahissante l'arrivée au kiosque en
bordure du plateau de terre plate permet
de réaliser une première pause et de
profiter d'un beau panorama sur le
cirque de salazie
on voit justement le village al bourg
qui est posée sur le produit de
l'érosion du cirque
donc on voit ses madeleines saas et de
mauvaises terres et donc c'était un qui
sont éboulées de durand pas tel qu'on
voit par exemple ici donc on a le
plateau de thé à plate avec ses
cryptomérias est juste à la base de
coûts plateau on voit déjà la terre qui
s'érode nom qui s'effrite planté en 1956
sur plus de 110 hectares la forêt de
cryptomerias de terre plate est l'une
des plus importantes de l'île espèces
exotiques nova e-sante le cryptomérias
été introduit dans les années 50 pour
organiser une filière bois à la réunion
bois à croissance rapide
il est principalement utilisé en
menuiserie
m
aujourd'hui confidentiel l'exploitation
des forêts de cryptomérias par le nfc
voué à disparaître progressivement au
profit de la reforestation indigènes
arrivé en bord de remparts on surplombe
la ville de la rivière du mât c'est le
moment de descendre dans la ravine en
pleine forêt primaire
changement d'ambiance radical au loin
les cascades qui s'écoule du massif du
piton des neiges
difficile d'imaginer que cette même
forêt était à la place des cryptomérias
de terre plate il ya seulement un demi
siècle après une centaine de mètres de
descente sans difficulté le sentier
rejoint le fond de ravine face au
sentier des fractures sont visibles sur
la paroi c'est d'ici que remonte une
partie des eaux de la source manouille
chargé en calcaire ces eaux sont dites
pétrifiante car elles permettent la
fossilisation des plantes alentours
elles sont également fortement chargées
en faire ce qui explique la couleur
rouge ocre déposés sur les matières
calcaire
un lieu agréable idéal pour pique
avant de revenir sur ses pas
c'est une rando qui est très coûteux
comparé à d'autres sur le cirque en une
heure et demie on peut arriver sur les
fameuses sur la fameuse source manui et
en très peu de temps on peut voir un
changement dans le paysage de
l'université dans la progression sur le
sentier on a le temps qui peut se
couvrir
donc quand on fait une marche assez
rapide dans un cirque pour voir les
paysages et rien de mieux
cette marche là c'est parfaitement face
est parfait pour ça il ya deux variantes
et donc on a le côté terrain el bour
donc c'est plus pentue et un peu plus de
dénivelé et cette variante convient de
faire aujourd'hui donc par iata vidocq
ça permet de découvrir et justement le
il est avide hot où la plupart des
randonnées un mât le connaissent plus
pour aller vers le pire chien ou la
traversée n'est rentable donc là c'est
une petite marche
accessible par il est avide est donc
parce que je n'aime pas dans cette
randonnée c'est l'aspect anthropisés de
du sentier c'est à dire que on voit que
ses proches de la civilisation
on a des plantes qui ont été ramenés par
l'homme dont qui se sont installés dans
dans ce milieu dans lequel la forêt
primaire existait auparavant et donc du
coup ceux des deux tiers de ce sentier
c'est que des espèces exotiques
envahissantes
c'est sur la fin où là on va vraiment
prendre plein la vue au niveau de cette
forêt primaire avec une diversité
d'espèces endémiques d'espèces de pieds
de bois pays
en plein coeur du village classé de
hell-bourg cette vieille bâtisse créole
typique des eaux est ouverte aux
visiteurs depuis une quinzaine d'années
avec son mobilier longtemps et son
jardin fournit la maison folliot et
notre curiosité de la semaine nous
sommes à lure donc un exode folio dans
la maison familiale tenue au casse donc
143 en maison qui a été construit à
l'époque où est lourd et une station
thermale ou que tous les notables bon je
venais monter prendre bien sûr à leurs
frais et ce long temps fréquenté le
gouverneur qui était aussi une autre
visite depuis 1995
c'est exactement mais qui donc est
typique e archi qu'hier créole fait
tient en bois de fer et en grande hâte
principalement qu'un mobilier d'époque
aussi john accueille le pire le jardin
typique idiart fluide plantations sans
ornement particulier avec bien sûr
partie floral partie importante dit
quand un parfum épices mines finale
moi ce qui me et danse à cette maison
c'est que bon c'est vrai que j'ai je
peux pas dire que je suis pas né ici
mais c'est vrai que j'y habite je
pourrais me repère je pige travail puis
c'est vrai que je suis dans un cadre je
pense que beaucoup de avortement ville
malgré tout qu'on parle de hq dix
bâtiments modernes gérer les anciens
avaient compris c'est quoi la chine lui
hq